Please welcome Noomi Rapace!
Spring just arrived!
Do you like speed?
I love speed.
I'm a speed junkie.
And I love cars, so yes, the two of us have that in common.
You should join me in a race.
Yes!
How exciting that would be!
I would love to join!
You also want to join?
No!
I would watch.
I would watch behind a protective wall.
Do you drive yourself?
I drive fast. I have a sports car ...
Which I love! I listen to really loud music.
I think well when I'm in cars. Like you said ...
You can find your form of ventilation. I think that I've had speed as a ventilator.
You are ...
You're now working with scent. You're working on a perfume ...
... that you've helped develop.
How much of a business woman are you?
I do things from the heart and from ...
... what I want to carry, what I want to share, what I want to give others.
And that's what this perfume creation started with.
It was something I needed desperately myself.
And also something I wanted to give to others.
The thing about scent, is that it is very much connected to our memory.
Yes.
What is your strongest memory of scent from your childhood?
It's incredible how much I remember ...
And how many memories from my childhood that are related to scent.
Both sad and good memories.
Boyfriends ...
Friends ...
And more than anything, my best friend, you could say, when I grew up ...
... who was a horse.
An Icelandic horse with the name Eldur.
And when I moved from home, I moved away when I was 15, I moved to Stockholm ...
And he was the one I missed, almost the most sometimes.
It was his scent, the muzzle ...
I rarely cried when I was little, I hardly ever showed my emotions.
So I would go out to the box, and he would come and lay his big muzzle on my shoulder.
So I would feel the weight, and his breath ...
You know horses, they breathe ... They communicate via breathing.
And I will never forget the smell of his muzzle.
So I have a lot of strong memories of scent.
What do you think is the worst, to smell too much sweat or too much perfume?
Well, that's a nice question!
Well, some of us are a bit sensitive!
Absolutely.
I think, rather not smell like sweat. But there's ...
... a lot of bad perfume, as well.
Yeah, because it can be really bad if you wear too much.
Oh God, yes, that's the worst thing!
It can be quite aggressive, too.
Like when you're a young man and a bit ...
... a little too generous.
It feels like you're trying to hide something, then!
What did the Rolling Stones smell like?
You did a video with them.
It's actually incredible ...
Mick, who I know quite well, he has such a young spirit.
And he danced non-stop for hours, and was sweating like ...
... really heavily, but he didn't smell at all!
It was really ...
He feels like a really fresh person.
But Keith Richards, he smells ..?
I wasn't that close to Keith!
So I don't know if he smells.
As I mentioned before, you broke your nose.
In a scene with Orlando Bloom.
An action scene.
And since then, you haven't learned a thing, because you constantly injure yourself!
You just did a film called Stockholm.
Which is about the drama on Norrmalmstorg.
And you got injured again?
Yes.
What happened this time?
I became blind!
I got a chemical burn injury on both eyes.
On one eye, I was blind for a week.
And in the other, my sight returned in a couple of days. But it was probably the worst thing I ever experienced.
In the end of the movie, about the drama on Norrmalmstorg ...
I think it was supposed to be the fifth day locked in a bank vault, and then the police sent in tear gas.
And the agent that the make-up artists used to create tears, swollen eyes and redness ...
They had cut open a Vic nose spray.
Which you're not supposed to use in your eyes.
And they had just opened them, so I got ... From the alcohol itself ...
A chemical burn injury.
And I couldn't see anything.
My friend and make-up artist, not the one who did this ...
... she had to help me go to the toilet, shower me, feed me ...
I was completely invalid.
But you've recovered now?
I'm perfectly fine now. But at the same time, it's a weird thing ...
... with actors, I laid there with my blindness and was thinking ...
«Now I know what it's like to be blind.»
«I can play blind now.»
It's like, you can use everything!
Noomi, you live in London. You've lived in London for quite some time.
Yes.
And ...
And, as I understand, you live with your sister?
Yes.
Your little sister?
How old is she?
23.
Have you always been close?
She is my best friend. She is my ...
I was like a mini mom for her, because she's 15 years younger than me.
I moved from home when she was born, so we didn't spend our childhood together. But we're catching up!
So I was like a mini mom for her, and then we became sisters, and then we became best friends. And now she's like a mini mom for me!
She's like: «You have to sleep more!»
And if I've been out late at night, I will take off my heels and tip toe in ...
... and be completely quiet. And the next morning, she will ask me: «When did you go home?»
«2-ish?» «No, I heard you at 4!»
So we're very close. I love her and I'm incredibly grateful that she's in my life.
When I see you again now, and it's been many years since we first met ...
You're different.
In a way.
How?
I might be wrong, but to me, you feel ...
... in some way, happier?
... than the first times we spoke together?
Yes?
Am I wrong or right?
No, but I feel happier.
I feel ...
... like I've landed in myself.
And that I ...
I can understand myself more. And that I have outlets for ...
... for everything that happens within me.
I don't clinch that often, I have less conflicts.
I'm less angry.
I feel happier, and more calm.
How did this happen?
It's a hard question to answer.
I think that I ... For people around me ... I grew up with ...
... a belief that you're strong when you're alone.
And that you're not supposed to show weakness, you're not supposed to share, and you're not supposed to show when you're sad or ...
... insecure.
But that means that you're completely in your own bubble. And it's hard to develop when you're alone.
And I've learnt ...
... that it's not a weakness to know when to speak out about feeling insecure or sad or ...
... or when you're in doubt.
I feel like I'm wrong a lot of times. And I learn from people around me.
And I just feel more open about that.
If you were to choose ...
Today ...
... what you value the most ...
... of ...
... freedom or belonging?
Wow.
What would you choose?
Freedom, I think.
Because within freedom, you can find belonging.
But if I don't feel free, I'll break up any belonging.
Good answer?
Yes, a very good answer, I think.